so the chances are you've looked in at
least one murder today you had achieved
or you combed it here or maybe you
checked your teeth for spinach after
lunch but what you didn't know is that
the face looking back at you isn't the
face that everybody else sees it's a
kind of reversed distorted bite to front
image so some years ago was on a flight
to New York and I read an article in the
FT and it was an article about a
phenomenon called a true mirror and for
the Americans listening that's a mirror
so the the true murder was actually
invented by a brother and sister team in
New York called John and Katherine
Walters and what we discovered was that
if you take two Meadows and you put them
together at right angles and you take
the seam away the images bounce off each
other and what you see when you're
looking at true murder is exactly what
other people see when they look at you
so I land in New York and I phoned
Joanne up and asked her if I couldn't go
and see him and I end up in his gallery
in Brooklyn and it was like being a
sideshow in the circus there were true
murders full length face size all over
this gallery and when I walked over to
the true murder for the first time and I
looked on the matter it was one of the
most disorientating experiences I've
ever had in my life the first thing you
notice when you're looking at true
murder is that your heads not on
straight so you're just kind of go in
that way and yours was quite straight
actually uses going out really bad so
apparently most of us tell our heads one
way or another so when you approach it
through matter the first thing you try
and do is fix your head but of course
because it's reversed you go the wrong
way so it's very very disorienting but
more importantly I had a flashback and I
had a flashback to when I was a wee girl
so I grew up in Glasgow in case you
haven't noticed I am Scottish but I grew
up in Glasgow and my mom when she was
putting her makeup on I used to love
setting watching my mum putting on
makeup or and you know where my ten in
my hands and I would tell it
occasionally isn't it funny how one say
the you top lip is higher than the other
your top lip and she look in the bone to
see that is no I see noise it's only a
couple of millimeters but that's a deer
Cupid's bow is definitely higher that
the other Society of Cupid's bow should
seek a lanyard Haven and when I looked
in the true murder
there was the left that I had been weird
and at that time for maybe 45 years and
I've never seen it so the difference is
when you're looking a regular murder you
look for reassurance you look for
reassurance that you're beautiful or
you're young or you're tidy or your bum
doesn't look back in there but when you
look in a true manner you don't look at
yourself you look for yourself
you look for Revelation not for
reassurance and this was deeply
interesting to me because what I do for
the leaven is I help people be
themselves not in any narcissistic or
solipsistic way but because I believe
that social Reformation begins always
starts with the individual and when you
look at remarkable individuals and when
I say remarkable or successful
individuals I don't mean monetarily
successful I mean people that have been
successful their achievement whatever
they say owed to do you'll find that the
thing they have in common is they have
nothing in common these are people who
you know work in many of the fields that
I work in I work with people in
corporations I work with captains of
industry I work with selected
politicians I work with geophysicists I
work with Chamber Orchestra's and belly
dancers and pop stars and all prisoners
and I've identified this thread that
links them these are individuals who've
managed to figure it out the unique gift
that the universe gave them when they
incarnated and then put that at the
service of their goals I think that we
all come complete we come complete with
one true note we were destined to sing
and these are people that have managed
to figure that out and it doesn't
dictate your choice of job what it
dictates is how you do it and when we
see these people we invariably call them
larger than life you know you'll you'll
see somebody like Roberto Benigni and
you
say oh my goodness is Eve Ensler she's
larger than life which always makes me
smile because I don't get to be larger
than life life is large but most of us
don't take up nearly the space the
universe intended for this we take up
the sweet space render tools which is
why when you see somebody in the full
flow of their humanity that's remarkable
but at least a foot bigger in every
direction than normal human beings and
these shame be green we glow it's like
they've swallowed the moon and all the
work I've done has led me to believe
that individuality really is all it's
cracked up to be and fight people who
are frightened to be themselves will
work for those who aren't afraid now
your job is not to be anything like any
of the people but I threw up behind me
in fact your job is to be as unlike them
as you can possibly be your only job
well you're here on the planet this to
be as good at being you as they are at
being them
that's the deal so I want to start today
by asking you an incredibly personal
question not the one that says why are
there so many syllables in the word
monosyllabic no even the one that says
did you know that Britney Spears was an
anagram for Presbyterian know something
I'm we've got more perfect all right
let's see the question that's been
looking for you your whole life it's
probably the simplest the most
complicated question you'll ever asked
and yet how many times in your life is
somebody offered you that well-meaning
piece of advice but you should just be
yourself how many times have you said it
to somebody else one of your kids comes
to you or one of your team comes to you
and they tell you the nervous they're
scared they have to go and do something
and their ball goes and you say it's
endowment just be yourself because when
you're yourself you're fabulous now
always resonates because it's all we
want to do if you tell Johnny be himself
he doesn't want to be Mary he's quite
happy being himself but it's the use of
the word just that I find interesting
because it would imply two things number
one that that was a nice
than you do number two that it was an
original piece of advice you know join
had never thought about himself when it
comes to being yourself when it comes to
being in the world a minute you showed
up
the minute you incarnated you were given
a life sentence no you don't know how
long you go maybe you go 70 years and I
got 62 with no idea how long we go
although where you're born when you're
born to whom you're born all these
things have a certain influence or
impact on how you become who you become
so if you're born in Switzerland chances
are you've got a long time you figure
this [ __ ] if you're born in Zimbabwe or
some parts of Glasgow and I'm not
kidding
you've got significantly less time so
what we need to think about it's not
what your life expectancy is but what do
you expect from life and what does life
expect from you those are more
interesting questions and the two places
in life where you are awesome at being
yourself you're fantastic at being
yourself one of them is when you're a
kid when you're a kid you're fantastic
at being yourself because you don't know
how it disguise your definis that's why
you see kids on the beach you know naked
up until the age of five and then
suddenly at the age of six or seven they
want a bathing suit they want a bikini
who's got who's got a four year old boy
anybody got a four year old boy I'll
take a three year old Jose you've got
three year old boy so what you imagine I
go into Eduardo's classroom school and
as a class my three year old boys and I
see in the boys who's the strongest boy
in the class what's going to happen
every hand right every single hand in
the class will go up they'll be
competitively strong if I go into the
same class but it's full of
seven-year-old boys and asked the same
question they'll see him because they
know by the time they're seven he's the
strong one
he's a fastest runner he's funny guy
he's the bully society archetype
America's roundabout age of five six
seven eight that's why the Jesuit seat
gave me a boy until the age of seven and
I'll show you the man because that's the
birth of consciousness and from then on
you become more self conscious than by
default less good to being yourself the
other place you're fantastic at being
yourself is when you're wrinkly because
you can't be arsed you get to that stage
in your life where you realize that our
more summers behind you than that out in
front of you and everything intensifies
you become more honest you become less
compromising so you're going to tell
people I don't want the spinach I'm not
gonna eat it I don't like it and I don't
like jazz so you can shut that noise off
and while I'm at it I don't like you and
we call these people eccentric we call
it all these eccentric and fight what
the doing is being authentic so it's
kind of like an hourglass effect when
you're young get great at being yourself
when you're old you're great at being
yourself
but the bet in the middle is sometimes
the most problematic that's about where
you have to socialize you have to
accommodate you have to adapt so I've
developed the I complex and the I
complex is a model to help you figure
out which I you mean when you say I
you're very familiar with the
superiority complex if you have a
superiority complex you pretty much
think you're the most important person
in the room you've got an inferiority
complex we suffer from an over modest
self regard now these are both signs of
a fragile ego one of them is about
delusions of grandeur and the other one
delusions of insignificance there's a
third way of being in the world and I
call it anterior this is one of my
made-up words so the word interior disty
describes a particular disposition and
there's two reasons it might be useful
to you number one it's completely
uncompetitive if you have a superiority
complex or an inferiority complex you
need other people around for the
superiority complex you need other
people to be smaller for an inferiority
complex unique you suffer from the and
gonna be found out syndrome
somebody needs to find your own teeny
oddity is entirely unrelated so to open
it from this position of interior duty
it's like a percent to a vantage point
it's a sensibility it's an orientation
and it's the only place in your life the
only place in your life you have no
competition try and find a comparison to
yourself and you'll draw a blank so I
could talk to you about interior duty
till my tongue bleeds or I could just
show you what it looks like so I won't
introduce you to a woman called Jill
Scott you might have it on your iTunes
playlist but Dells is saying it and
she's just about to go onstage and
perform and in case you missed the
question there's a French filmmaker
who's filming her she's going on stage
after Erykah Badu and he says to her are
you nervous
you know going on after Erica I don't
you to listen II what she says
I am a poet and a singer
and a lot of other things we all have
our own thing that's the magic when
everybody comes with their own sense of
strength and their own queendom see you
doesn't even know you had a queendom
that's what it looks like when you think
about it be yourself it's an incredibly
liberating on tragic way to go through
life so you don't develop an identity
that's pretty cases don't being a
patchwork personality you're not a
composite an amalgam of all your
experience and influences you're not
just somebody's boss or somebody's mom
or anybody's anything you're yourself
however the chances are that at least
four of you sitting in each of those
chairs so let me introduce yourselves
the most visible you that you represent
to the outside world
is what everybody else thinks of you and
there are as many opinions of views that
are people I want you to imagine you're
like a big USB stick and you plug into
the world you show up on the desk top of
the world and that's the power of
context if you don't understand that but
being yourself can be an ill-advised
strategy so of course it's important
that you understand perception but one
of the things I've noticed in terms of
gender and I'm terribly untrodden by the
way I don't find myself
tragically women I describe myself as a
womanist
rather than a feminist but I'm also a
card-carrying feminist there are very
few things that I think are gender
specific but one of them is something I
call approval addiction the need to be
liked the need for approbation or
recognition or for somebody to tell you
it's okay I find more women suffer from
that affliction than men and I think
it's one of the most ability
when it comes to being yourself neither
another people's approval 11 somebody
else's opinion and mistaking it for your
own it's one of the most debilitating
things we'll do on the road to being
yourself you will never ever be
perception less but it's important to be
perception free what are the things
that's going to help you to be
perception free it's to tune into the
next circle of the eye complex so this
is your wish mhm this is what you would
like everybody else to think of you and
it's not about being feed or a fad or
pretending it's about moving is about
possibility is about potential it's
about supposition so whilst there's a
part of you that's like your backbone
this part of you is like you're your
wishbone this one is your adaptive
personality your construct self and even
that's unique because nobody in the
world has had the same experiences or
influences that you have but this is the
you that keeps moving that keeps
changing all the time and it helps you
avoid being one of those people you know
the people that say to you they have 15
years experience when they mean one year
15 times they literally repeat
themselves year after year after year
what I want you to think about is with
every passing year your job is to be
better and better at being who you
already are this is not a cosmetic
exercise you're already different your
job is to figure out how and then to be
more of that now there are certain times
in your life that lend themselves to
change that make change quicker deeper
and I call them intervals of possibility
now they're not always as well
signposted
as this one but you know there's times
in your life when you come to a
bifurcation on the path and you stand
that the potential for change is
heightened you meet a stranger than a
bar you get to decide what you're going
to do your boss comes to you and offers
you a new job you know what do I do you
want you to keep doing the same thing or
do you want this job and you know that
if you make that change the speed of
your life will change
now unfortunately some of these
interventions some of these intervals of
possibility a catastrophic in fact most
of them are catastrophic because most of
us would rather sleep walk until
something happens to week is up and what
will happen is somebody you love will
get sick or you'll get sick or you'll
get fired or maybe it's something
impersonal maybe 9/11 happen so the
tsunami happened so the Kashmir the
earthquake happens but something happens
that rocks you back and to that and
herself and makes you ask the question I
asked you at the beginning of this talk
and the problem is when it happens
catastrophic wickley it's you're
vulnerable you're weak and my question
is why wouldn't you ask yourself these
questions when you're strong from a
position of health when you're in a job
when you're loved that's when the
questions become more useful
so the question on this one is if you
could be the woman of your dreams who
would you be and my tongue is nowhere
near my cheek when I ask you that
question
the thing that might stop you being the
woman of your dreams is the next circle
and that's what you think of you so now
you've got what everybody else thinks to
you what you would like everybody else
to think of you and this is what you
thinking you and you have good days and
bad days right there's days when you
wake up and you think you're the bee's
knees and other days you wake up and you
can't even say your name even your cell
phone feels too happy so on the days you
wake up and you feel that you're the
bee's knees it's not even like you've
got a reason
it's like free-floating joy and your
body just looking for a target and you
know how it feels in those days because
you just think somebody gets me an
audience I'm on fire
quick point me somewhere and your hair's
fabulous and everything just works
everything works on those days but the
other days nothing works your legs don't
work your mouth doesn't work either word
thief comes and steals your entire
vocabulary those are two extremes of
your ego and one of them is about self
congratulation and the other one is
about self-castigation know your entire
life I don't care who you are I don't
care how
you are your entire life from birth up
until now has been about building a
stable relationship with your ego you
need an eagle to live in a Western
capitalist world if you don't have an
ego you'd be toast but your challenge is
to take the Eagle from its dominant
position and pull it back so that it's
in service to yourself that's when it
becomes beautiful and in order to do
that you've got to find the still point
right in the middle of those two
extremes so that's what I would call
equanimity or equilibrium and it's the
kind of state of mind that cannot be
perfumed in any way by anything that
happens outside you this kind of
confidence that comes from there is like
the confidence of the sky all right you
know is this dark outside but you know
if you went up in a plane even in this
stormiest of days the sky's brilliant
blue underneath so when you look at this
sky and it's made a rainbow and it's
absolutely gorgeous there's no question
that this guy is up there going did you
see my rainbow or when it's a terrible
that he's you know green gloomy day that
the sky is going to apologize
no the sky just as because the sky sees
the impermanence of the clothes and the
impermanence of the rainbows and you
have to develop an inner state of mind
this is impervious to all the good shirt
and bad chipper happens to you as the
sky as to the weather now we would also
call this in a western context we would
call best feeling a feeling of humility
and I worked last I had one day last
week where I got to work with UK sport
and particularly I got to work with the
the amazing coaches who worked with the
amazing Olympic athletes who got all
those amazing results at the Summer
Olympics it was incredible at the in the
same room is four hundred of these
people and the woman who runs UK sport
is women called Baroness Campbell and
she gave me a definition of humility
that's as good as any I've ever found
she said she Millie humility is not
thinking less of yourself
humility is thinking about yourself less
and I remembered lemon in that lesson
when I was a regional and probably no
more than 78
it was actually the woman with the
squinty Mouse that taught me the lesson
she had no idea my mother what she was
doing to me as I was growing up but when
I grew up in Glasgow particularly
working-class steel industry Glasgow
nobody had any money so nobody could
afford to go out and be entertained
everybody's social life happened in a
house so the weekends all the wrinklies
and all the kids would show up at
people's houses and they would you know
drink till the kneecaps were on
backwards and all that kind of stuff but
everybody at some point in the evening
had to perform and it was a riot because
these people were bus conductor susan
and welders and carpenters by day time
but then they'd show up at nighttime and
come nanny Frank Sinatra and Dean Martin
and theater Vaughan and bellyache scene
they were old
my house was it was like a star-studded
affair living in my house and all the
kids were taught to perform as well and
so I'm the oldest of four girls my
mother had four doors so did my father
interestingly enough but we were brought
up from any age to perform and we'd be
wheeled out at least family parties me
with my guitar and my sisters around me
and we'd have to sing and we would
literally be positioned Hosea like the
Von Trapps you know my father would say
Benedetto over there Luiz over there and
then we would sing and we were terrible
we were absolutely rubbish so one night
my mother came up together then we were
all upstairs having pella face never
since you showed up she had rate last
he's everybody's ready go down and give
them a song and that's May I was just
overcome I said I don't want to sing she
said why do you know what to say I said
I'm shy
she said what you shy for I said well
everybody's going to be looking at me
and I'll never forget her face she
looked at me she said Caroline don't
flatter yourself darling you think
anybody down the stairs is interested
and you don't know your jobs to go down
there and make me happy so go and sing
Sookie and I picked up my guitar and I
picked up my sister's and you know what
that advice has never left me but what
it has left me worth is spectacular
disregard for where my abilities in and
spectacular disregard for being the
center of attention and fight since that
day
I have never been the sensitive
attention you're the sensitive main and
that's a very different feeling so last
the last two and the opposite of least
is the ever-present unchanging you there
simply you that you've been since you
were seven and the you that you'll be
when you're a hundred and seven please
god I spend a lot of time in India and
in India you're raised with us feeling
that you're a spiritual being who
happens to be in a physical body where
is we in the West much more and to our
physical bodies and then if we get old
enough and long in the tooth enough we
can't get interested in spread it but
now if you've ever been to the Gandhi
Museum and daily you'll know that this
is the line that's above the door and it
was actually a response by Gandhi to a
question from a journalist so Gandhi was
getting on a train and the jungle is
cold after them Gandhiji
Gandhiji what's your message to the
world and Gandhi Tom Drona said my life
my life is my message
and your life is your message to might
not be as big a message as Gandhi's mein
certainly isn't but your life has to be
your message otherwise why are you here
it's not like you've got spare so when
you think about your identity when you
think about what it means to be alive
when you think about why you deserve to
exist you note your thoughts because you
thank them and you can't be your
feelings because otherwise who's the you
that feels them you know what you have
you know what you do you know even who
you love for who loves you there has to
be something underneath all that and
when you look at people who have managed
to transcend all these judgments that we
put upon them you know this man here he
couldn't be judged as a man or a black
man or young or old or Democrat or
Republican or a gay or straight it
really really wouldn't have mattered
because he knew why I was here yes we
can
so you see he seemed to be a variable
and even when you're born without many
of the attributes that some of your
peers may have even when you're born in
a way that may lead you to feel impotent
if you can tap in to that voice if you
can tap in to that inner voice that I've
been talking about you might just end up
being 12 years old the youngest person
ever called to the national world
champion swim team
you may even end up at the age of 13
being the youngest Olympian gold medal
winner ever you might even end up at 14
being the youngest person ever to get an
MBE that's what happens when you dial
into the personal pronoun so if you can
do this not only will the speed of your
life get quicker not only will the
substance of your life get richer but
you will never feel superfluous again
thank you thank you
[Applause]